is the right word i was going to say i
do disagree with your definition of
privilege just because you know if
you're rich there's certain preferential
treatment you get from people but you
worked hard to become rich yeah so and
so i think it's rich privilege though i
think there is yes there are certain
things afforded to you because you are
rich people treat you differently
because you are rich that's true so with
the biggest privilege it's yeah
it's if anything money is equalizer so
so i was asking would you
would you say somebody is more
privileged if they started from nothing
and became rich or somebody inherited
that richness i don't think there's any
because i could be born poor and then
become a billionaire i'll be very
privileged so i don't think it has
anything to do with that i would say
that i'd change my stance there might be
such a thing as thing privilege but i
don't think it's a bad thing can i ask
what made you change your stance because
i'm thinking about it you know based on
the different initially i was thinking
of definition privilege as something
that you
character that you're characterized as
inherently and it gives you an advantage
in life
but then now i'm thinking of you know
you can work hard and become rich and
become privileged because of it so i
don't think it's necessarily something
that's inherent to you but
when i hear privilege i just think of
something you're like born like when i
hear rich privilege i don't think if
someone that was broke and became rich i
think of someone that was born rich yeah
i get what you're saying i get that but
i think it does
being rich does give you a certain
privilege but no matter how hard you
worked for it yeah but when you say
privilege like i think of something you
didn't earn yeah what's the what's the
difference between gaining privilege
because you got to a certain position
and then gaining the perks that come
with that position
so can you could you rephrase that so
what's what's the difference
right so like for example like if you
say for example oh um you you become the
i don't know let's say you become a
pilot right which means that part of
your privilege as a pilot is you don't
have to go through security when you
travel
right is that a privilege or is that a
perk that you gained from gaining a
position oh i see the difference because
if you compare the park you can kind of
say that being fat
is a privilege now because of as a fat
person you get a privilege of calling
people fat phobic
for privilege
is
a marginalized group can be a an
advantage right in these days in this
current um
you know yeah but being incredible the
context we're speaking about is um you
know sort of weight what
that let's iron that out
can message someone like chris evans
knowing fully well everyone knows she
has no chance of him but she can message
him
why would you why is she messaging chris
evans why would she
can message someone like chris evans
okay even though most people objectively
know that she doesn't have a chance with
him and he still has to respond nicely
because she's big right when people are
asking him questions um questions about
it in tabloids however on the other
let's say rosa reversed and chris evans
was a really fat man and or really short
and he messaged someone who was
extremely good looking like rihanna
people be like why is this guy in her
dms like that
i think that's i don't think that's to
do with her being fat i just think
that's men and women though
how do you mean
you can't equate that because yeah the
other
what i would say is equal to that is
rick ross
messaging rihanna but he really is
different because exactly the same way
without rich it's just a different
ballgame exactly
it's an exception to the rule hence why
lizzo being fat and rich and got clout
is an exception but women get privileged
being fat oh my god you just got no no
no no
i'm gonna i'm gonna show you guys some
tick tocks all you gotta do is shake
your rolls and get a freaking following
yeah like that's because they're
breaking from the mold they're doing
something that is actually kind of
risque wow that's so brave take off my
clothes and show them my role it's more
like shoehorning i think so maybe not
maybe maybe not brave that sounds quite
i don't know assertive but in a way
because it's the european beauty
standards they are kind of in a way
doing a level of bravery by showing look
at me i look like what the world doesn't
want me to look like essentially so
following is that a privilege sort of
like you get you get you get a reward
for being ugly
okay but this whole thing i think is
more of of um
i think it's more like when the social
constructionists try to
because okay so there are people who
believe that what people like is being
taught to them or being told to them
like people are told what what this is
beautiful this is not beautiful right so
i think those same people um in the
let's say the fat positivity uh
movement
they're trying to that's their their
basic beliefs that they're they're
trying to
uh create
this new form of beauty whereas that's
not how in reality that's not how we
look at things like we instinctively we
know what's beautiful and what's not
right but also why doesn't it it's
gentlemen like short men or absolutely
yeah
where's the broke man positivity
you will you will never have a shout out
one at a time guys one at a time no
sorry i didn't hear anyone shout
shouting that oh yeah we we want men
who's more dicks
you're never going to i don't hear
anyone saying that so why is that not
poor body positive body positivity and
it wouldn't be a good thing if that
existed
i'm not saying it should be a good thing
and i'm not saying that it should be
there but let's not pretend that there's
not
objective truths in the world and
objectively certain things aren't seen
as attractive yeah and other things are
it's a fact so when you try to prop um
to push a narrative of body positivity
it should go both ways and always not
just the one that suits you yeah so i
have a question what what would you say
are you european beauty standards and
who is the celebrity that you think of
when you think of europeans
so we'll talk in
slim thick not even necessarily thin i
think that the blue
yeah slim thick she's got tiny waist
perky breasts but she's bottom heavy
okay um little cute button nose
um fair skin type i'm talking to
basically it's sort of within my culture
basically is what i'm describing
um and yeah sort of like really
exotic mysterious sort of like features
i would say that's the standard and if
we're really honey on the body though
slim thick back in the day you would
have been like yeah just thin just thin
is the basis of it but i think nowadays
you've got you know the kim kardashian
and that whole movement and
kardashian isn't you're she's armenian
she is armenian but i do think it's a
whole other conversation yeah i do think
her family and the
the narrative that they've pushed on
certain things in terms of beauty and
body shape i think has
hands down had an impact on culture and
body shape and things like that
especially within the black community i
can say that i'mma die on that hill
because that's just true
but i think that that is the european
beauty standards what i've just
described
um but it's just it's just interesting
because when like
based on what you're describing like
you're describing one person and then
you used kim kardashian as an example
and i don't feel like that was who you
were describing
really because i think people are going
for the kim k look at the moment like
yeah
you're you've got two tiny five no right
describe slim thick is a woman who is is
slim like a slim sort of waist it's what
i'm trying to get to to be honest slim
waist perky breath and bottom heavy
that's why i say slim thick she's thin
and i think the european standard is
more blonde hair blue eyes yeah
that's just what you said earlier oh
yeah yeah blue and you know i mean blue
white's blonde hair obviously would be
the european standard but in terms of
like standalone would you say that i
don't think that's the only standard
like i i personally don't think there is
one standard because there are a wide
range of women who are beautiful like
like there is a limit like there's
there's too skinny and then there's
there's too fat but there is there's
there's a there's a large section in the
middle where there's all sorts of
beautiful body types so like yeah adam
lee there's there is one beauty standard
remember we're talking about the
european standard so if we looked at the
catwalk